foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
well good evening welcome to a quite
historic
show Piers Morgan uncensored breaking
news former president Donald Trump is
under arrest inside the federal
courthouse in Miami facing 37 criminal
charges of his handling of classified
documents at Mar-A-Lago his Florida home
this is real history unfurling Donald
Trump becomes the first current or
ex-president of the United States to
ever face Federal criminal charges and
again it's for all the wrong reasons
because Trump has done this to himself
and as a result he could now face going
to jail tonight we're bringing you the
very latest from the United States and
asking big questions about America's
future which in so many ways is the
world's future could Trump run for
president from behind bars you wouldn't
put it past him all these federal
charges mock a Tipping Point in the
battle of the soul of the Republican
party or Will trump again defy the odds
and emerge stronger than ever well in a
moment of reaction from outside the
court but to put this historic moment
into context joining me now is criminal
defense lawyer Jane weintram Jane thank
you very much indeed for joining me uh
how serious how serious is this
this is extremely serious I represent
people every day in this Courthouse
except for today because all of our
hearings were postponed until tomorrow
and they're actually evacuating downtown
Miami where I'm sitting as we speak
it is very serious he's looking at gel
he's looking at Espionage charges
conspiracy charges he made our country
vulnerable that is unacceptable he has
made fun of our constitution he has made
fun of our judges he's impugned the
Integrity of our court system it is the
very core for which I live for 31 years
practicing law so I find it offensive
and I find the evidence very serious and
there is a qualitative difference isn't
there between the charges from New York
in relation to alleged harsh money
payments to Stormy Daniels the porn star
and this this is an altogether totally
different and way more serious series of
charges yes I mean the case in New York
is you know paying off a hooker and not
entering it on his books properly I mean
please give me a break and I am not a
drum supporter however that's ridiculous
compared to what's going on here in
federal court what's going on here in
federal court are very serious felony
charges that have been launched against
the former president of the United
States historic indeed sad is the real
word for the day and let me ask you I
mean obviously we're into unprecedented
territory just with these charges but
then there comes the case if well if
Trump is convicted could he still run as
president and the Constitution
apparently allows that could he even if
it came to it could he actually be
president from his prison cell if he's
convicted in jailed and again I believe
the Constitution would technically allow
that to happen
I do too and it it is crazy obviously
our forefathers never envisioned such a
disgraceful situation occurring
um I do think that he can run for
president it's clear that he's not going
to be bored from running for president
um it's another story if he is convicted
in sentenced you know remember what
what's really at the Crux here is the
cover-up to me pierce the cover-up is
worse than the crime you know what was
the crime keeping classified documents
but was that really the crime no the
crime is the cover-up the crime was when
the government came in and said Mr Trump
you have to return these documents they
have National Security information we
are vulnerable to other countries if
this gets out
and he refused he refused and he entered
into this whole long journey to deceive
uh the United States government from
recovering these documents and he did
something else that was horrible he put
his lawyer at risk I mean if you can't
speak to your lawyer in confidence and
know that will remain confident that's
terrible and that's the message of today
but the real thing about the
attorney-client privilege of being
pierced pardon the pun is that if the
lawyer is being used to facilitate a
crime of fraud then there is no longer
that attorney-client privilege in other
words you can confide in your lawyer I
killed somebody a week ago and the
lawyer can never repeat that however if
you say I'm going to kill my lawyer next
week or I'm going to kill somebody else
next week the lawyer has an outright
obligation to report future criminal
conduct that he knows of or she knows of
to the authorities
we have a clip I think of uh the Trump
lawyer Helena Haber let's listen to this
the targeting prosecution
of a leading political opponent
is the type of thing you see in
dictatorships like Cuba and Venezuela
what is being done to the president
Trump
should terrify all citizens of this
country
well joining me now is the former
Arizona governor nominee and Rising Star
Republican party Carrie Lake who
remained a big supporter of the former
president she's outside the court there
in Miami uh carry him in extraordinary
scenes they're obviously unprecedented
we've never had any current or
ex-president of the United States
indicted on federal charges and most
people I've I've spoken to I'm just
hearing by the way breaking news Donald
Trump has pled not guilty to these
charges but most people I've spoken to
from a legal point of view describe
these charges as indeed Jane wildtrop
just did as exceptionally serious and
certainly way more serious than the
charges relating to Stormy Daniels and
hush money payments so what is your
response having read the indictment
well you're right we've never seen this
happen before because we've never had
someone as corrupt as Joe Biden sitting
in the White House turning our
government against our people we've
never had someone like Joe Biden who is
in fact a criminal himself who's taken
bribes from the CCP who's taken bribes
from Ukraine and many others having to
turn and weaponize our department to go
after his rival and this is election
interference Donald Trump is an innocent
man he will be found innocent at the end
of the day and the American people are
fed up they're tired of watching our
government being weaponized against us
and this is outrageous there was a
beautiful show of support for president
Trump there were many people showing
that President Trump waving the
president Trump flags and it was really
a nice setup down there where a lot of
people came out to say we're tired of
this and we're tired of our government
being turned against us I mean the
problem I have with that Gary I've read
the indictment closely and apart from
anything else you hear him on tape
Donald Trump clearly conceding the
documents he has have not been
Declassified something he always said
he'd done uh which many lawyers say is
just a fat accompli right there that
he's admitting himself that these are
not Declassified documents and he's
sharing the details with other people
I sure wish they would share with these
documents are they're being very mum
about what's in them I'm really curious
about what's in them and Pierce there's
more evidence of wrongdoing and crime
frankly in uh on Hillary Clinton servers
there's more evidence of crime in Joe
Biden's Garage in those boxes where he
had no ability to declassify those
documents because he was a Senator and a
vice president and frankly there's more
evidence of a crime on Monica Lewinsky's
dress than in those boxes that were
pulled from Mar-A-Lago and everybody
knows it everybody's tired of this
charade
his administration is is is illegitimate
as well okay how do you know that Carrie
how can you be so sure a what's in the
documents and how do you explain that
even when he was asked to give the stuff
back he didn't
you know what the president has the
right to take the items from the White
House it's happened with Obama it's
happened with previous presidents it's
happened with Bill Clinton they have the
right to do that and presidents have the
right to declassify documents they don't
even have to announce that they can just
think about it and they can be
Declassified it doesn't matter this is a
bogus case and you know what it is it's
really just a way Pierce to give cover
to Joe Biden who just this week we found
out took another 5 million dollar bribe
and payout from the CCP and we have 17
recordings of him according to Senator
Grassley on tape being recorded taking
bribes and payouts from Ukraine this is
a distraction to give you in the media
something to talk about so you don't
have to talk about the crimes Joe Biden
commits
about for the next five years I have no
truck I have no truck in defending Joe
Biden from anything or Hillary Clinton I
was savagely critical of Hillary Clinton
throughout the whole email Scandal I
thought that was outrage ages and I do
think there are legitimate charges of
double standards here particularly from
the liberal skewed U.S mainstream media
about the way they've treated Hillary
Clinton's emails Joe Biden's documents
and others I think it's a completely
valid point but that doesn't in itself
negate the severity of what Donald Trump
is accused of doing here so my question
to you is if he's actually convicted
hang on Gary if he's convicted is it
really realistic that Donald Trump as a
convicted felon on serious federal
charges would continue to run for
president or indeed win the White House
which he couldn't be in
Pierce you haven't you haven't been in
the states um recently to find out just
how corrupt our government from top to
bottom this government is corrupt the
judicial branch the doj the CDC the FBI
this entire Administration is corrupt
and Donald Trump is an innocent man we
know that this is just another which no
you believe it
but we don't know that ever since we got
it this has been one thing to give you
guys something to talk about stop
talking about you guys like we're all
the same I don't have anything in common
with a lot of the media that you have
this big problem with but what I would
say about this is I read the indictment
these are serious charges and I don't
think that the special counsel who's
leveled them could be deemed to be a
partisan guy so there's a possibility
Trump gets convicted so my question
again if he is convicted should he or
could he run for office
you can indict a ham sandwich conviction
is a whole other story and he should run
for office he's not going to quit Donald
Trump is the only person standing up for
We the People our government has turned
on us right now we have an illegitimate
Joe Biden sitting in office weaponizing
our government against his lead rival
this is election interference they know
they can't stop president Trump they
know he has the people behind him they
know he's going to win and they keep
trying to throw these other candidates
in trying to get the American people
excited about these other people and
they're not they want president Trump in
office and the only way to stop him is
to throw bogus indictments at him and
try to arrest him and stop him okay a
court of law is going to destroy support
okay this is not going away you you
believe they're all bogus and you have a
touching loyalty to Donald Trump I want
to play a clip this is from you I
believe on Friday talking about what may
happen
if you want to get to president Trump
you're going to have
75 million Americans just like me and
I'm going to tell you yep
most of us are card carrying members of
the NRA
foreign
that's not a threat that's a public
service announcement we will not let you
lay a finger on President Trump
frankly now is the time frankly now is
the time to cling to our guns and our
religion thank you Georgia
that's pretty incendiary stuff Carrie to
suggest that you've all got your guns
and you're going to use them to defend
Donald Trump
that's not what I said I am using my
freedom of speech to say that we support
president Trump Millions hundreds of
millions of Americans do and the
law-abiding gun owners in America are
not the trouble it's the outrageous
rioters on the street that you know the
media has supported Don Lemon defending
antifa calling it peaceful protests we
know what you know you guys you guys
will always defend Community
you guys
have you watched my show
actually did Don Lemon ever have you on
his show like I have I I see I see how
you constantly attack Trump and I know
that that's what your network wants
because that's their narrative nothing
to do with the names that I work for and
by the way I have regularly supported
Trump on his warranted support and I
have regularly criticized him when I
felt he deserves criticism now I'm
taking it yeah I'm taking a more down
the line position which is he has been
indicted with very serious charges you
may not like it but you don't know that
he's innocent you just hope he is
Pierce this this whole government is
illegitimate right now under Joe Biden
it's completely gone Bonkers and they're
they are they're weaponizing our
department of justice it should be
called the department of Injustice right
now against Trump when the real criminal
is sitting in the white house right now
he doesn't even know where he is his
name is Joe Biden he has taken tens of
millions of dollars of bribes and
they're trying to deflect and put the
attention on Trump to give you in the
media somebody to talk about and
something negative to say about Trump
has been for eight years just for the
record I haven't mentioned Biden other
than when I've responded to you so when
you say you the media
it's like me saying you politicians as
if you're all the same you're not so
stop calling me you the media anyway
I've got to leave it there but it's
always a joy to catch up with you do
work for one of the big you you work for
one of the corporate Giants you work for
Rupert Murdoch and I understand he is
for making sure Trump doesn't get into
office and you know that's who signs
your check Pierce so you got to go alone
you said this last time I have had
absolutely no instruction from anybody
of fox to have any opinion about anybody
that's just not what happens there you
might think it does nobody has ever said
to me I know what I should say about
Donald Trump it's worse than you think I
say things I actually mean I'm one of
those guys in the media I've worked in
the media for 30 years under one of
these corporate Giants I won't name who
and so I understand this subtle pressure
you get all right
I'm going to leave it there not because
I'm cutting you off but because you've
had more time than we allocated I've got
to get to other news
having you on the show it's always
robust but just for the record nobody
tells me what to think you'll say and
that's why it's called uncensored
Carrick great to talk to you same here
God bless you thank you Angie uncensored
next what does this mean for the future
of the Republican Party Megan McCain was
a rather different view to the one we've
just heard joins me live
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
well welcome back to Facebook and
uncensid an historic moment in American
history Donald Trump has treated not
guilty to all counts and called in Miami
facing 37 criminal charges over his
handling of classified documents he's
the first current or former president to
ever face federal charges commentator on
author Megan McCain joins me now well
Megan I just had a very robust defense
of Donald Trump from Carrie Lake uh yeah
I can't imagine you shared I just say I
think you're like No And I think you're
one of like the most even killed
journalists at work thank you I didn't
understand thank you antagonistic that's
when she says
outrageous but Megan great to have you
on the show I was like you were
literally fired for free speech thank
you anyway thank you to be here as well
it's great to have you it's a pleasure
to be here as well what is your wrinkle
what is your reaction to this really
quite historic moment I mean this is the
first time any American president
current orex has ever been charged with
federal charges this is a big moment
oh it's huge I mean it will be something
that my children will read about in
history books and it's you know it's
it's really disheartening it's really
depressing as an American it's
embarrassing I mean the global culture
is watching us and you know seeing
what's happening he's the by far the
front runner as you saw with your last
guest there are people that will vote
for him if he is you know sent to prison
and would be running the country from
prison so it's amazing to me that um you
know he's he's accused of 37 counts it's
a lot uh you know General Petraeus
almost went to jail for three so I I
think we're in a situation that is
obviously unprecedented and
um you know unusual Waters but that's no
different than anything we've dealt with
with President Trump I'm interested to
see how the current group of people
running for president on the Republican
ticket are going to be handling it going
forward because right now a lot of them
are defending him right I mean that's
the really interesting question isn't it
because at some point the Republican
party has to make a decision about
whether it can actually go forward with
a guy who facing not just State charges
over hush payments to a porn star but is
now facing 37 incredibly serious charges
on Mr Diamond you know about under the
Espionage Act about basically using
classified documents or into nuclear
power to you know to how you would go
after enemy States and so on this is not
chicken feed this is serious stuff
no and look I woke up this morning to
the news that I read online that um
there was a person who had gone to the
White House and appeared topless at a
pride party over the weekend and I was
just saddened and also horrified at the
state of different kinds of things going
on in the country uh Joe Biden is
incredibly weak candidate 75 percent of
independent candidates voters don't want
him running for president uh 80 percent
of Republicans over 50 percent of
Democrats don't want him running for
president Republicans can literally only
lose this election if we nominate Donald
Trump and it looks like that's what
we're doing and I think we're going to
have to have a really hard look as as to
what our party but also what our country
is going to look look like with him
being the front runner that being said I
don't see a lot of Courage coming out of
Washington D.C and courage coming out of
these candidates running there's no one
I'm particularly excited about including
Ron DeSantis and none of this is good
enough and I think part of it is if you
walk this line where you're going to you
know suck up to president Trump and want
to get his supporters but at the same
time I want to you know differentiate
yourself from him it's not something
that's going to be possible and I do
think there is a lot of voter fatigue
and those 75 percent of independent
voters are going to make or break this
election and if there's one thing we've
learned they do not like President Trump
I mean look this whole debate around
Trump has got so toxic so tribal you
know I've had times when I've supported
Trump and I've had times not least when
he attacked your great father when I
felt his behavior has been completely
sickening uh and demeaning of anyone
who's ever held the office of President
so Trump is this kind of character where
you can like him for some things and to
test him for others but he's got this
extraordinary Stranglehold over a large
number of Republican voters and if
you're going to try and beat him for the
for the nomination you've got to somehow
as you've just rather well articulated
you've got to somehow bring those people
with you without trashing their hero
it's difficult
yeah and your last guest um you know not
to make it too personal but she went
down that road and told anyone who voted
for McCain to get the hell out and
that's exactly what happened to her she
is not the governor of Arizona no matter
what she thinks in her brain and the
exact same thing will happen to
president Trump he has lost Arizona a
very valuable swing state this will come
down to three swing state states in the
United States of America as it always
does and president Trump has lost all
three the last two election Cycles so
I'm not exactly sure why we continue to
put our cart next to this losing horse
especially given as you said the
historic circumstances today but you
know I'm I'm 38 I'm a different
generation I'm a different voter
demographic and there just seems to be a
lot of quite frankly older Boomers that
have a Stranglehold on the party and
want to see President Biden get
reelected and I for one don't want an 86
year old to be president uh leaving
office in the next cycle I think that's
a very dangerous precedent for our
country and my understanding is I work
at a UK publication at a job you used to
have at the daily ill that a lot of our
friends across the pond think it's quite
bizarre that we have a president that's
this old and would be that old if
re-elected well he could have a choice
at the 2024 election if things go the
way people fear well you have a man who
appears to be senile against someone who
might actually have been convicted of
federal offenses under the Espionage Act
I mean it's a completely extraordinary
situation
yeah and I think it's why a lot of
people are looking at RFK Jr I'm not a
fan of his nor a supporter but he has
upwards of 20 percent of democrat
support right now independent support
coming strong and I don't think it's
that he's a particularly interesting
candidate or politician uh you know I
think he's an activist married to a
famous actress but I think it's just
that people are just so thirsty for
anything that's different than these two
candidates and just from a you know
holistic standpoint for the American
people this is a very depressing very
scary time to have these two men as the
most powerful men leading both parties
and I think it's a recipe for disaster
and I quite frankly think it's a recipe
for even more disenfranchisement of what
people call the establishment what
people call uh you know as Curie Lake
was saying like people in media circles
and establishment media I don't adhere
to that line of thinking but it does
make you very cynical about who's
running things and I think an example of
that is the Democratic National
Committee is not allowing President
Biden to do any debates I think the
American public deserves to watch him
debate to any of the candidates who are
running for president and like I said
RFK Jr has over 20 percent Marianne
Williamson has 10 percent these are not
numbers that any Democrat strategist
should be ignoring right now yeah I
completely agree uh Megan always read
your columns in the Daily Mail they're
the second best columns the males ever
run obviously
you always provoke thought and that's
the best thing about being a good
columnist so thank you very much Steve
for joining me I appreciate it
thank you
so what does this all mean for the
future of the Republican Party in the
2024 presidential race okay live
pictures here of a courtroom in Miami
where the recently deposed president
Trump has just been charged with 37
counts 37 involving classified documents
of the most top secret stuff involving
America's apparently evolving America's
nuclear program uh its plans for
potentially attacking enemy States and
so on very sensitive stuff that he
shouldn't have had in the first place
and then when he was asked to hand him
back according to the indictment he
didn't had a lot of it back
um so these are serious things and you
can explain away Trump defend him as
much as you want feel like you know he's
getting a hard time the indictment is
serious when you read it joining me now
is the conservative radio host Ben
Ferguson the host of the Reuben report
Dave Rubin all right guys uh there's a
battle raging here now for the soul of
the Republican party and a real quandary
what does the Republican Party do about
this growing number of legal issues that
Donald Trump is facing Ben Ferguson yeah
where are we here Donald Trump oh yeah
the Stormy Daniels stuff you can sort of
joke that away say it's trivial bit of a
Witch Hunt stupid I don't disagree with
that particularly but this stuff when I
read the indictment is very serious if
this was Joe Biden and it was leveled at
him or Obama you would be leading the
charge probably to have him executed
not executed but I would be leading the
charge uh for classified documents if
you're going to have this level of
accountability for a republican then
then damn it you better do it for
everybody on the left that has also done
this and there was no accountability and
this is going to be why this is not a
big issue in the primary for Donald
Trump there was their accountability for
Hillary Clinton the three thousand
thirty thousand plus emails literally
telling her staff to take hammers to
blackberries and cell phones zero
accountability and that's going to be
the talking point for Donald Trump I
think he actually gets closer to the
nomination uh today with this indictment
because there are so many Americans
conservatives that are sick and tired of
a two-tier justice system where this
system goes after Republicans and looks
the other way when there's meetings on
tarmacs uh between former President Bill
Clinton uh and the Attorney General
talking about Hillary Clinton they've
had enough of it now does that mean that
this is going to be a good thing for the
Republicans and the Gen General I think
it's way too soon to tell peers But
ultimately right now there's a lot of
pissed off Americans that are sick and
tired of this two justice system here
and there's a lot of examples of it for
goodness sakes look at the day they
charged him you've got Intel that
apparently five million dollars went
from one of the executives at barisma in
a bribery scheme to the sitting
president United States of America and
the majority of the mainstream media was
silent on it so okay are people shocked
by this no they're not they're angry
over it let me bring in Dave though
because the issue to me is there's also
a political element to this and if I'm a
republican this rapidly coming a point
when you have clear options I mean you
could have Ron DeSantis I went down to
Florida interview I thought it was
pretty impressive he's a genuine
conservative he's been wildly successful
in Florida turning a 33 000 majority
into one and a half million he's Trump
without the baggage he's very trumpian
in all of his policies you know Trump's
tried to rubbish him and rubbish what
he's achieved it's obviously in my
estimation like nonsense that charge why
would the Republicans want to pursue the
Trump Road to nomination when it's so
fraught with potential danger and when
he might be the only person that could
actually let Joe Biden win
well the short answer to that is that
Trump does have a certain captivation
over the world in the last you know
decade or so that allows people to
follow him whether things are working or
not working look at the moment I agree
with you and with Ben on this idea that
the the thing that people are most upset
by at the moment is the selective
prosecution and persecution of Donald
Trump when they see the asymmetry that
Biden and Hillary and and even Mike
Pence says VP can get away with
classified document things and Donald
Trump can't that asymmetry is what
bothers people but on the DeSantis front
I I completely agree with you peers we
have what I think and you know I I moved
to Florida during covid in large part
because of Ron DeSantis and moved my
family here in two companies here and I
have a ton of flourishing people that
I'm around now in a state that is
functioning I would say really at the
Pinnacle of the world for Freedom right
now uh we have a guy who has done
everything he has set out to do in his
legislative agenda he has fought the
woke he has got the neo-racism out of
the schools he's gotten the gender stuff
out in effect he beat Disney he's doing
all of the things that anyone who is
conservative minded or or right-leaning
or roughly Republican or even a
disaffected liberal which there's a lot
of people I think you're probably a
little bit in that category uh I think
he's the guy that can get everybody out
of this but but that's sort of a
separate issue than what the base of the
base the carry Lake types who I like how
she's on one hand calling you a sellout
and then also saying God bless you I
love talking to you uh that they're
never they're Never Gonna Leave the
they're Never Gonna Leave the Trump
orbit but I think there Ron DeSantis
offers a chance for a whole bunch of new
people to come into the fold Trump I
just don't see where the new people are
even putting aside all of the
indictments and the craziness where are
the new Trump voters that's a good
question yeah let me bring Ben back on
that I mean the real issue is who can
win the independence for example yeah I
just don't see Independence exactly
liking any of the this they're all just
looking at this aghast and I don't
disagree with you by the way there are
legitimate allegations of double
standards in the way that Hillary's
emails and Joe Biden's documents and so
on have been treated by the liberal
skewed mainstream media I completely
agree with that but purely on Trump and
what he's done here and what we
apparently are going to hear from his
own voice on a tape where he concedes
these are not Declassified documents
contrary to everything he's been saying
this is a real sort of Damocles hanging
over the party and you could end up with
the most damaged candidate in history
and that might be the only way Biden
notwithstanding all his issues ends up
winning so why is the Smart play for the
Republicans not to go for a much safer
option of yeah right a great question
look I like Rhonda Santos I I said this
I don't want a Civil War the night after
Rhonda centers announced and I said if
you took Donald Trump's name and refer
to him as Kenneth a and you took
desandra's name off a page and say can
it be both of those candidates the
Republican Party would be jumping up and
down and screaming over the difference
though appears as this there's a big
asterisk now next to any accusations
against Donald Trump and the reason why
many Americans than in this especially
in this primary and going into the
general are saying we don't believe you
when you tell us that Donald Trump's a
bad person you said he was colluding
with the Russians we now know that the
Deep State lied to us the top FBI and
CIA directors were lying to us and they
signed that letter also saying the
hunter by laptop was not real not
authentic and it was had the markings of
the Russian government
again
I know the line you're taking on this
and I don't disagree with you I thought
the Russian collusion thing was a load
of trump top nonsense no pun intended I
thought the way that the uh Hunter Biden
laptop thing was suppressed uh by big
Tech was outrageous
um but ultimately this we are where we
are and I still I still believe I still
believe that the Trump route to victory
for the Republicans in 2024 is fraught
with danger
um
he's gonna make is he's going to say Do
you believe me or believe them because
there are lots of people lots of Mega
supporters that will believe him David
my final question for you
um
who is going to win the nomination give
me a name
I really think Ron DeSantis is going to
win the nomination I think the polls are
closing I think the more people get to
see him get to see the competence the
clarity his ability to communicate the
right ideas C is track record he's 44
years old he's younger than me he's got
three young kids fantastic wife in the
first lady of Florida Casey DeSantis I
think he's got the right message without
the baggage and I think as time goes on
I think you're right Pierce people are
getting tired of this that is not an
excuse related to The Selective
persecution of trump but people everyone
has a limit to how much they can take
and I'm hearing from an awful lot of
people when I travel the country they're
like we thank Trump we appreciate Trump
he woke us up he red pilled us but that
doesn't mean he has to be king forever
[Music]
guys I'm gonna leave her there but it
reminds me very much of our situation
with Boris Johnson in this country look
at the donations does Santa's got a lot
of money coming in follow that as well
because there's a lot of people out
there writing him big checks right now
and people said oh he's dead in the
water I don't think he is at all
honestly in the debates also I would
look at the scores on the board as
DeSantis told me when I interviewed him
I'm a school's on the board guy and he
wins and Trump in the last few years has
been a perennial loser guys go leave it
there Ben Ferguson Dave Rubin thank you
what a great panel really appreciate it
thank you very much
and since the next one on the pack will
be to give the their reaction to Donald
Trump's called appearance and the
breaking news in the UK did on two big
stories that's after the book
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Adrian and told to be presenter Richard
Tice okay well welcome to all of you
let's just segue to a story that's
really taken off in this country Richard
this is the mother jail for taking
abortion pills way after the legal limit
she's a mother of three she received
abortion pill medication uh following a
remote consultation during the covert
pandemic where she lied about how far
pregnant she was and she's now been
jailed for this what do you think of
this case well I've I mean it's a
tragedy and you can't imagine what she
was going through she knew how pregnant
she was but of course what many people
are forgetting it was seven weeks into
lockdown everybody is is varying forms
of terrified she can't get any uh
face-to-face consultation whatsoever and
she's made a decision that most people
would say is is awful
um but really A two-year sentence
actually 28-month sentence I what's why
not suspend it you've got to have a
deterrent but what's it going to achieve
locking her up for 14 months the people
can be impact on her three children and
you might be surprised I don't take a
sort of a difference actually I bumped
into Ava last night and I was all fired
up about it thinking why why are the
liberal left coming out so vehemently
this is all outrageous given how far
pregnant she was and what she did but
actually the more I looked into it the
more I've heard people talk The more
I've come around to your way which is
imprisoning her for two years but she
has three kids given the circumstances
it seems to me too Draconian I mean even
from a fiscal perspective it's not good
for the taxpayer to put her away I mean
look she's no threat to the public and
she's not going to do it again you know
she's not going to get any kind of
Retribution by going inside look the
whole thing for me has sort of been like
a Witch Hunt and I think it has been not
you that I'm not talking about you but I
think a lot of people have sort of
jumped on it and used I've actually not
I've not deliberately said anything or
even tweeted anything because I think
it's a real minefield and I do believe
in a woman's right to choose what to do
with her body we have some of the most
lacks compared to the rest of Europe and
America abortion laws as it is but the
problem here is she did almost Go full
term and many people do feel very
strongly about that in even in this
country about this and they also feel
well what's the point having a law with
a punishment for that law if you can
break it with impunity and get no
punishment well I'll push back on you
slightly and say we actually don't have
that that easy access actually if you're
living in Scotland or you're living in
parts of the north it's extremely
different I've been on term limit being
24 weeks you know Poland Poland you
can't have illegal abortion at all and
actually a lot of women are dying in
Poland
I think you're misunderstanding me I
support a woman's right to have an
abortion I'm just saying that there have
to be limits and there are legal limits
and the question then Paula becomes well
what do you do as punishment if somebody
breaks them so horrendously she clearly
has and admits she has what do you do
well I think the problem that a lot of
people have in commentating on this is
whether this actually requires a
punishment was this actually a crime now
legally speaking of course it was
um and the judge couldn't uh Grant her a
suspended sentence because she didn't
plead guilty exactly but he did say
didn't he that if he if she had pled
guilty he would have suspended given a
suspended sentence first time so that's
like a double deterrent Factor well and
it's built him within the sentencing
guidelines the judge acted appropriately
and nobody is denying that
um and so what I want to ask is where
was the public interest in terms of this
crime and I don't think there was what
we have is a tragedy that I hope is
going to mean that we now start to
re-look at what was a statute book of
over 1861 before women could vote we
knew little in terms of science not only
medically but also psychologically it's
now time to look this again clearly and
there must have been massive extenuating
circumstances because of the pandemic
you couldn't see anybody face to face if
she had seen someone face to face she
wouldn't have got the pills I suspect
because people would have said hang on
you're way way too long I think that's
24 weeks that's me was what I thought
and so there were massive extenuating
circumstances and there would have been
counseling provided for her what a lot
of people don't understand is that it's
actually not unusual to go five months
six months and not realize that you're
pregnant it's a shock for a lot of
people but actually it's not that
unusual and so that kind of resource was
not available to her and I don't know
why that wasn't taken into account all
right let's have a quick what about
Boris Johnson is he finished
never write them off uh he might be
finished within the conservative party
for a fair while but never write him off
he's just
he in a sense you should never write off
Donald Trump when you've got these huge
personalities you just don't know how
they're going to reinvent themselves and
I suspect he will be the same Ava well I
mean rich is the perfect person to ask
because I think we're all wondering I
mean Nigel farage had quite a lot to say
about you know this possible comeback
with Boris Johnson I mean you're the
party that they would you know who would
host them so I'm quite interested are
they coming back they're not they're not
coming back because we would you take
him though would you take Boris Johnson
uh we have very significant differences
of policy I wasn't a no we have very
significant differences of policy let's
put it like that was that yes or no
it's a question of fact but we do we do
all have the three of us have to protect
the brexit Legacy because at the moment
it's being Trashed by a useless existing
government that doesn't believe in it
all right Paula final word to you Boris
Johnson toast or not toast toast he's
not going to get the funding the backers
have gone you know the last person
everyone condemned repeatedly throughout
his career as toasts and never coming
back Winston Churchill
it's a horrible thought that you could
compare it
he did write a very good book about
Western churches are they Boris is going
right populist history like he intended
to she'll finish his Shakespeare book
and do all that kind of stuff he's
actually good at those books I just
don't want him running the country again
sorry
sorry well he's good at anything that
stuffs money in his mouth
uh on that bombshell thank you very much
Pat I appreciate it on since the next
Donald Trump appears in court and Boris
Johnson stands down as an MP both crying
conspiracy and witch hunts but are they
really victims
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk we're following
the shocking news from Nottingham where
three people have been killed including
two University students Donald Trump
makes a historic appearance in court
accused of stealing classified documents
and the Beatles make a comeback thanks
to AI That's all at nine
[Music]
welcome back to pleasure on both sides
of Atlanta the real reputations of the
blustering blonde Bombshells are
dangling by a thread former prime
minister Boris Johnson and former
president Donald Trump both by witch
hunts and conspiracies whether
unraveling do they have a case or are
they both really from the same populist
Playbook joining me now is former
director's strategist David Cameron from
the future contributors and by former
conservative MP Louise mench Louise I
want to read you a letter that someone's
just tweeted from the timed letters page
today and it says perhaps its most
important mission for Eaton College
will be to ensure that its pupils are
saved from a sense of privilege
entitlement and omnis omniscience that
can produce alumni such as Boris Johnson
Jacob Reese Smog quasi-karting and Ben
Elliott and therefore damage countries
very Fabric and here's the Stinger sadly
I failed in that purpose John clawton
Master Eaton College
1984-2001. wow when the Eaton teach it
start distancing themselves from what's
been going on what do we make of that
will I make of that as the sound of a
guy that loves his own voice and somehow
thinks he's important if I remember
correctly uh Boris as a young man went
to Eaton on a full scholarship he didn't
pay money for it because he was a clever
kid who was fluent in Latin at the age
of seven years old and when you started
out peers you said is there a similarity
here between uh Boris Johnson getting
kicked out by basically a quango who
didn't like him
um who are in my opinion very up
themselves and who have kicked him out
of parliament in a quasi
wait a second wait a second this quango
as you put it is made up of seven people
four of whom are conservative brexiteers
not quite sure how it works that they
would be the ones leading the charge
against Boris well at least one of them
is not a brexiteer but isn't Ardent to
remainer and the others have some kind
of personal beef with him I think we all
saw Bernard Jenkin during that that
questioning it's pretty clear to me that
he doesn't like Boris I thought he asked
all the questions I'd have asked if
Boris Johnson ever gave me an interview
which he doesn't Steve yes
Steve Steve the similarities between
Trump and Boris do you see them people
used to always say they're different I'm
not so sure that difference is quite so
wide now
I totally agree I mean look clearly
their backgrounds are incredibly
different but the way they're behaving
and the way they've been treated I think
it's similar I mean it was really
striking to me uh reading boris's letter
the other day that he literally used
that word Witch Hunt which is now such a
kind of key part of Trump's political
messaging if you if you watch a trump
event these days the people in the
audience behind him literally holding up
signs saying Witch Hunt yeah so that's
very similar I think the other thing
that's actually more substantively is
similar is that one of the reasons I
think they they produce such vitriol
from their opponents is that in
different ways at different times they'd
really challenged the policy basis of
the kind of establishment group thing
for many many years Boris obviously with
brexit where people in charge thought
this is unimaginable we can't leave the
EU how dare you same with Trump in the
challenges he brought to big issues like
the US's relationship with China wars in
the Middle East and so on these to
really deep challenges to the way people
there's no problems it's the similar
problem between them both is that they
you could take a lot of boxes for good
things they did no question you could do
that with Boris with Ukraine and other
issues that he did in my view very
impressively but are they both their own
worst enemies in the sense that is most
of the trouble completely because of
their own behavior and conduct it's so
funny you should say that I was just
looking up peers that famous saying
about a politician it was Labor
politicians in the past which is he's
His Own Worst Enemy someone said and
someone else said not while I'm alive
um and I think there's a lot of people
that would say that about those two and
I think you're completely correct that
their own behavior has contributed to it
but again you you can say well that's
the price you pay for disrupt disruptive
attitude in the business world you see
it the whole time especially here where
I am in Silicon Valley these great you
know founders of tech firms often behave
in really terrible ways excusing it yeah
but you know the point is well that's
what you get when you get these
disruptive figures yeah listen I think
with all great men there are often
thoughts we're looking at live pictures
this is Donald Trump we think leaving
just to bring you up to speed he's been
allowed to leave court without
conditions or travel restrictions no
cash bonds was required he can't talk to
another age has been indicted Walt
router and he will speak tonight at his
golf club in Bedminster New Jersey at
8pm local time it's 1am UK time Louise
um on Boris the big question is can he
come back
uh and I guess the same same question
sort of applies to Trump but he's kind
of still there albeit is indicted can
Boris really come back now the parties
seem to determined to get rid of him
he can't come back right away he can't
come back until after the next election
so let's just push a pin in him but I
really think that the comparison between
Trump and Boris is ridiculous Trump has
been indicted by a grand jury in an
actual legal process as you said earlier
these are very serious crimes and the
idea that he's being treated unfairly is
frankly nonsense a special counsel was
appointed to look into every other
single politician that took away
classified documents Trump had loads of
chances peers to avoid what's happening
today he was asked to give the documents
back if he'd just given them back he
wouldn't be in a courtroom today it's
his own fault can he run for president
from prison look if he's elected the
supremacy clause he'll be out of prison
and he'll try to Pardon himself okay but
I think he's and I think it's terrible
for the GOP if they don't let go this
dream of Donald Trump they are going to
lose to joburg
Steve let me ask you one question or two
questions who is going to be the
Republican nominee and who's going to be
the next president of the United States
give me two names
okay first of all just want to say
absolutely agree with everything Louise
just said to your questions I think the
GOP nominee will be Donald Trump and the
name I'm going to give you for the next
president Gavin Newsom governor of the
state California wow right okay
fascinating response uh Steve Louise
thank you both very much indeed greatly
appreciate it that's it for me whatever
up to Keep It Uncensored we are watching
history on fall tonight Donald Trump
indicted on criminal charges again but
this time federally it's serious stuff
and this story will keep rolling good
night
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]